today I'm going to start with two
different stories about Challengers to
Joe Biden and Donald Trump respectively
in their 2024 primaries for Joe Biden
the Democratic primary for Donald Trump
the Republican primary we're going to
start with some really interesting clips
from an interview that Fox News
propagandist did last night with Bobby
Kennedy Jr Robert F Kennedy Jr who's
running as a democrat in the Democratic
primary challenging Joe Biden now I
don't know whether I need to rehash My
overall view about Challengers to
incumbent presidents running for
re-election but to be 100 percent clear
I support challenges to incumbent
presidents Joe Biden doesn't have any uh
particular claim to the Democratic
nomination just because he's an
incumbent anybody who wants to run
against him should I would like like to
see debates I get why the DNC isn't
going to do them because why would you
ever
put your uh current president from your
party in a position where they can
really only damage themselves and I
understand why the DNC isn't going to do
debates it's not unique to the
Democratic party it's not unique to Joe
Biden it's not unique to 2024. that
being said the current Challengers to
Joe Biden Bobby Kennedy Jr and Marianne
William Williamson are not particularly
impressive to me now before we get to
the interview you have to understand
something
really specific that's going on with
right wing media
and the people challenging Biden right
now meaning Bobby Kennedy Jr and
Marianne Williamson Marion Williamson
was also interviewed by Hannity last
night we're not going to look at that
interview today but maybe we will later
in the week and one of the things you
have to understand
is that Kennedy and Marianne Williamson
are useful to right-wing media as ways
to criticize Joe Biden and to criticize
the Democratic Party
they don't actually find these
candidacies interesting on their merits
the Bobby Kennedy one is interesting
because it's an anti-vaxx candidacy so
that might be one way in which it is
interesting but when Hannity interviews
Marianne Williamson if you look at that
interview there was a whole bunch of
focus on mult five six times trying to
get Marianne Williamson to say she
believes Joe Biden is suffering from
severe cognitive decline
it's not because Hannity thinks
Marianne's platform is valuable that
he's having her on he's having her on to
try to get her to attack Biden on
something he wants to see Biden attack
done and similar similarly with Bobby
Kennedy Jr it's not that the anti-vaxx
actually is interesting but it's just
another way to criticize Democrats and
to attack the DNC okay so that's the
context of why these right-wing shows
are interviewing people like Bobby
Kennedy Jr and Marianne Williamson that
all being said
Sean Hannity asked Bobby Kennedy Jr
since you're an environmentalist
are you swearing off private jet travel
and Bobby Kennedy Jr fails hard
this is an example of what happens when
you're totally unprepared
Bobby says and again remember Bobby's a
nice guy I had dinner with him once we
have many friends in common but I I
think the candidacy is ridiculous I
think his anti-vaxx activism is
ridiculous
he first says he is not someone who
regularly flies on plot private jets or
he kind of like I don't fly on the much
totally unprepared and this just looks
terribly this is it looks terribly look
at this you were getting on a private
jet have you given up all use of private
jets of your environmental abuse I was
literally laughing out loud when I saw
this this morning are you really going
back to that Sean
but that's a simple question did you are
you pledging to never have you given up
the use of private jets
John I don't fly on private jets I don't
regularly fly on private jets I don't
regularly fly on private oh okay I'm not
regular up any use of somebody if
they're
yeah listen I've never objected to
people listen I think this climate
alarmist stuff is a bunch of crap so I
don't care if you do or not but if
you're claiming to be a big
environmentalist you shouldn't be flying
on a private jet right
I'm not that kind of environmentalist
I I he's a private jet environmentalist
guys I have been fighting for against
pollution on the rivers and water
against coal and pollution against
carbon pollution because of the toxicity
of those things
I have not told people that they
shouldn't fly on private jets okay this
is really bad guys this is also so
stupid because listen private jet I mean
all jet the the harvesting refining and
burning of jet fuel
pollutes Rivers you know he he's acting
like no I focus on like Dupont leaking
chemicals into a river oh Rivers well
okay what do you think happens with the
production and the burning of jet fuel
all over the country it gets some of it
gets into rivers
this is just it's not serious this is
not this is none of this is serious this
is embarrassing and humiliating and it
is a gotcha from Sean Hannity it is a
gotcha from Sean Hannity but it's one
that you've got to be prepared for you
really have to be prepared for it there
was another moment I want to look at
here
where and remember Bobby Kennedy's
Democratic campaign
is one that is extraordinarily pro-putin
it's conspiratorial it's anti-vaxx it's
a lot of things that the kind of
do I want to call it the regressive left
likes we'll get to it in a moment he
brings up a con totally unfounded
conspiracy theory about what's going on
in Ukraine and by the way what we're
doing in Ukraine is not good for the
Ukrainian people we have killed 300 000
Ukrainian troops 14 000 civilians well
Europe Europe has stepped up we have not
killed any Ukrainian troops we have not
killed any Ukrainian troops I'm trying
to think what on Earth is he talking
about what could he mean we've killed
300 000 Ukrainian troops Russia has
maybe I don't know if that's even the
number Russia has killed Ukrainian
troops but only if you interpret this to
mean
that we the U.S
caused induced or forced Russia to
invade Ukraine could you say we have
anything to do with the killing of
Ukrainian troops so this is really
Bonker stuff just the Chaos Agent per
Steve Bannon right the user Steve Bannon
term this is a Chaos Agent and my
colleague John sent me this article this
morning from the new Republic the
article is called who were these
supposed lefties who love Robert F
Kennedy Jr and if you read the article
and if you just look around online you
very quickly realize that even though
he's nominally running as a Democrat
Bobby Kennedy Jr is running a sort of
combination Pro Putin
uh anti-us sort of campaign it's
appealing to those folks who are often
in League with people like Bashar
al-assad and Vladimir Putin and the
Maduro Chavez regime of Venezuela and
then it's also people who dabble in
anti-vax people who dabble in
anti-science conspiracy theorists
opportunists Etc it's certainly not a
progressive campaign
um and to even call it a democratic
leaning campaign uh doesn't really make
sense so that's what's going on on the
Democratic side people challenging Joe
Biden and again I say challenge them
bring everybody in everybody should run
run against them okay but that doesn't
mean I have to celebrate and welcome
every individual campaign let's now talk
briefly about the side challenging
Donald Trump so we don't yet know
whether Ron DeSantis the Republican
Florida Governor is going to enter the
race and challenge Donald Trump's
seemingly uh unchangeable path to the
Republican nomination one guy we know is
running is Vivek ramaswamy and I'm going
to play for you we're not going to spend
a lot of time on this this is basically
just almost satire at this point
Vivek ramaswami was interviewed on Fox
News
and he now is jumping into the tears in
my eyes stories
I don't understand what the obsession is
with with people crying for these
Republicans but you may know that Trump
is known for telling stories most of
which we believe are made up of people
coming to him crying with tears in their
eyes and Eric Trump sometimes will jump
into it Donald Trump will sometimes tell
these stories and the way these stories
go is you know Eric Trump will say
listen I boarded a JetBlue flight the
other day I fly commercial all the time
and as I boarded everybody stood up and
cheered and a couple of guys came up to
me and they were crying and they were
saying you've been treated so unfairly
we've got your dad's back and then
usually we listen to that story and we
go nobody was doing that nobody nobody
burst into tears on a JetBlue flight
over uh Eric Trump just being there so
anyway it's the with tears in my eye
stories Vivek Rama Swami now claims
that at one of his events a guy came in
wearing a Maga shirt the guy went up to
ask a question started crying and then
abandoned supporting Trump and decided
to support Vivek ramaswamy our friend
Aaron rupar tweeted filed this under
things that didn't happen take a listen
to this one of the people who actually
stood up at that same event was somebody
who walked in with Trump shirt broke
down in tears as he asked the question
thinking about the country and what we
were doing for his children said he was
switching over to vote for me I'm
absolutely running for the presidency
could that possibly be true like it it
also to honestly
there's nothing wrong with crying there
is nothing wrong with crying and if
anything we maybe have a lot of people
who have been sort of culturally
conditioned not to express emotion so
this is not about there's nothing wrong
with crying but what what sort of
circumstances would lead to you being a
trump supporter but you go out I'm going
to go to vivex event but I'm going to
wear my Maga shirt and then when they do
questions you say even though I'm a
trump supporter I'm going to ask a
question and then in the course of
asking the question you're so overcome
with emotion for how wonderful what
Vivek is proposing is a guy who's
pulling what three percent that you
break down in tears and say I'm
abandoning my support for Trump and now
I support you while crying it's either
an obvious lie or a sign of
extraordinary emotional instability
nothing wrong with crying that scenario
strikes me as Bonkers totally and
completely Bonkers so do we believe this
I don't believe it I don't believe it
you tell me whether you think that story
could even possibly be true
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course an
audience supported program we really
just will do this for as long as people
want us to do it and uh for as long as
we have the resources to do it and much
of that comes from you by signing up at
joinpakman.com we offer the commercial
free show every single day in audio or
video form to all of our members we also
do an extra show every single day called
the bonus show we have a whole bunch of
other great perks you can read about at
joinpakman.com we are going to look at
part two of Carrie Lake versus Piers
Morgan now this is a I find these
conversations genuinely interesting I'm
not a big Piers Morgan fan and as I've
said before uh I I now just ignore
requests from his show to be on because
they've now like four times
David can you be on in two hours we're
gonna send a cardboard a little and then
it's just like gets canceled you know
five minutes before and it's just a
waste of everybody's time I find them
unprofessional I think that the show is
kind of a mess
but every once in a while Piers does a
really good interview
last time that um Piers Morgan
interviewed Carrie Lake who of course
lost her gubernatorial race in Arizona
uh she really made herself out to look
like a fool and she was in London
um over the weekend or over the last few
days she did another interview with
Piers Morgan and these go so terribly
and of course I don't think Harry like
realizes it she promotes it as I face
down Piers Morgan or whatever a Piers
Morgan accurately tells her listen stop
going back you you lost in 2020.
wouldn't it be better I'm sorry 2022
wouldn't it be just better to stop
talking about how Trump won 2020 and
stop talking about how you won 2022 you
guys didn't win and look forward and
Carrie Lake apparently doesn't agree
because she's got to keep the grift
going you and Trump both refused to
accept the result of democratic
elections and I say to you in all
sincerity I think it's a it's a it's a
vote losing premise that's fine to keep
saying I didn't lose when you did you're
better off going I lost that time next
time I'm going to win I totally
understand that I understand what you're
saying and I would just ask this when
you voted when was the last time you
voted right here yes uh in the last
election okay so you voted if you'd
shown up and they said you're gonna wait
five hours and 61 of the polling
locations had function non-functioning
equipment none of this is true remember
man you waited five hours you showed up
to vote and the tabulator refused your
ballot and they said you know what go
down the road would you be okay with
that you have to approval we have proven
you haven't proven that you have proven
it you haven't it's been independently
established you haven't proven I wish
you were there you say you were robbed
Trump says look Trump in the face and
I've liked Donald personally a long time
but since him I don't know why you keep
saying you won the 2020 nobody wants to
go back because they think they raise is
money on it I don't know if they still
do look forward offer America a positive
future
give them a reason to vote for you next
time banging all about 2020.
yeah listen I agree completely with what
Piers is saying and it really does seem
you know that there was a while where it
seemed like it was actually a good
strategy to keep harping on that and
there was a while where the balance
seemed clear you're attracting more
people and money than you're turning off
by continuing to talk about how you were
robbed even though many Republicans
still do believe Trump won in 2020 and
some believe Carrie Lake won in 2022. at
this point it seems like it's becoming
increasingly a net negative because it
just doesn't offer a vision of anything
and what's even more delusional is that
in a subsequent moment during this
interview
Kerry Lake when she's asked by peers
about listen are you going to run for
Senate now in Arizona
she continues to talk about getting the
right outcome for the 2022 election
again we are now
five and a half months
from the anniversary of her losing in
Arizona and she is still claiming we're
fighting it we're fighting it Katie
Hobbs is the governor of Arizona that's
it but she keeps talking about you want
to be sentenced to it I want to see
three elections awesome my question
I'm not sure what my future holds to be
honest I'm working right now on our
election case that's the center of my
would you like to be senator of Arizona
and and if for some reason we don't get
a fair outcome in our election I won't
run for Senate most likely you will most
likely so you're declaring now no I'm
saying most likely if we don't have a
fair outcome in now of course she's not
going to be crowned governor of Arizona
so I guess she's saying she's going to
run for Senate she calls it getting a
fair outcome what she means is somehow
stealing somehow kicking Haiti Hobbs out
of office which is not going to happen
Katie Hobbs is the governor
um so I guess she's saying she's going
to run for Senate our election case that
I may consider running for Senate Donald
Trump says he wants you to be his
running mate what do you say we've had
this conversation come on I said if the
royal family invites you in and they
want you to come in I said yes you said
yes
I don't think president Trump needs a
vice president he's that powerful
that's a cop that's a cop-out if I've
ever heard one we know Carrie is
desperate to be Trump's VP desperate
desperate to be Trump's VP but that's
really something Trump is so good
he doesn't even need a vice president
wow there's an idea if you're wrong he's
that powerful as a leader he doesn't
really need one but I do hope he picks
somebody who the media fears more than
they fear him is that you and you know
why I think he should do that because
then they'll stop trying to take him
down
all right so I mean you can get the gist
of just how completely debased and
disconnected from reality Carrie lake is
we'll look at one more clip of this in
this one
um Carrie Lake pulls out the big
pharma's controlling everything thing
and this is the context of saying we
can't really talk about the truth of
vaccines it's an anti-vaxx rant riddled
in an anti-corporate round she can't
talk about big Pharma just like you
can't talk about the music industrial
complex because they control the media
controls me you cannot talk about big
Pharma famously nobody controls me you
cannot know you can't talk about big
Pharma right now you can't talk about
how dangerous the vaccines are well but
that's not true you can't talk about it
I don't think the vaccines were
dangerous really no you're not seeing
some of the consequences no I think the
vaccines actually were a remarkably safe
okay let's talk about something we could
probably agree on yeah the vaccines were
remarkably safe I wish they worked
better at preventing transmission
but the vaccines were extraordinarily
safe and so this is this is a common
refrain so this you really have to go
beyond just a single sentence and delve
into this whole big Pharma controls sort
of thing it is absolutely true
that pharmaceutical companies are large
advertisers on TV most countries don't
even allow direct to Consumer
advertising uh you know do you feel
tired in the morning you might be
suffering from what right they spend a
ton of money advertising their products
they spend money with pharmaceutical
replica that's all absolutely true they
are profit driven all of those things
are absolutely true and also the scale
of pharmaceutical companies has led to
incredible advances in our ability to
treat and in in some cases I wish it
were more prevent disease uh keep people
alive in circumstances where they
previously would have died like that's
all all of these things can be true at
the same time
but there are numerous examples of
investigative journalism news
organizations doing in-depth uh
investigations into the practices of
pharmaceutical companies we've seen
what's happened over the last 10 years
with reports about opioids and um the
the ways in which the pharmaceutical
companies have lobbied and pushed for
more prescribing even though they knew
that these were highly addictive these
things are featured on mainstream news
programs all the time and independent
programs as well in 2020 CBS News had
this major investigation about the cost
of prescription drugs and they actually
interviewed pharmaceutical Executives
industry experts patients who couldn't
afford medications NBC News in 2019 had
a major series about the opioid epidemic
and they interviewed families that were
affected they they did investigations
into how pharmaceutical companies were
promoting the use 2018 ABC had another
one uh about
um uh opioid there all of these examples
so what they want to do
is normally they say let companies do
whatever they want don't don't limit
them don't regulate them whatever but
now that we want to talk about
supposedly dangerous coveted vaccines
which weren't dangerous which aren't
dangerous now all of a sudden it's
you're owned by the Pharmaceuticals and
nobody can talk about it and it's all
everybody's being silenced and whatever
the case may be Kerry lake is
fundamentally not a serious person and
my hope is and from all of the data I've
seen
uh she has a shot at being Senator if
she runs My Hope Is that she is soundly
defeated in 2024 if indeed she runs for
the senate in Arizona much more soundly
than she was defeated by a much larger
margin than she was defeated in Arizona
in 2022 running for governor and quite
simply she lost the person who got more
votes is now the governor and that's the
right outcome the latest in a series of
attempted replacements for fired Fox
News propagandist Tucker Carlson is
Donald Trump's own former press
secretary one of the most dishonest
people in the Trump Administration
Kaylee mcinanny she gets this week to
try replacing propagandist Tucker
Carlson her first episode last night was
a pathetic joke the likes of which you
would find at the bottom of a barrel a
media Barrel a proverbial media Barrel
she opened her own show
by showing some of her speech at the
2020 Republican National Committee I'm
not going to play it but we're just
showing you you know a screenshot from
that her first guest was the Texas
Attorney General and he was on not to
talk about we've got to do something
about guns we've had this terrible
shooting in Texas and Allen no no no no
no the Texas Attorney General appeared
with Kaylee mcinanny Ken Paxton to talk
about how bad gender affirming care is
for Trans kids and then this was really
just the cherry on top I guess we would
call it former democratic congresswoman
Tulsi gabbard appeared to call Trans
people mentally ill and essentially say
that there's no such thing as trans she
says really crazy things here and this
is one of the most disgusting one of the
most disgusting Tucker Carlson villains
that I've seen so far let's listen to
the last real liberal remember when all
these supposed leftists were saying the
only real left Winger running in 2020 is
Tulsi listen to this
well Kaylee this should give us some
hope to see that there is still some
sense of of Common Sense and Sanity in
our society because this is the real
question that we the American people are
being faced with we have leaders in the
Democratic party unfortunately and those
in our society who are are pushing this
fantasy they're asking us to take
something that is clearly not real and
believe that it's real they're asking us
to take something that is very clearly
amended it's not real mental illness
that creates this delusion where you
have people saying well I'm a man in a
woman's body and what's weird about the
mental illness thing is that for a long
time
homosexuality was very clearly a mental
illness in the DSM Etc and then we sort
of like came to our senses and realized
just about every animal species has a
percentage of what we would call
um
I don't know if the term homosexual is
used for other species but you
understand what I'm saying and then we
realize oh actually like there's there's
this isn't a mental illness we should
stop trying to like treat it with
medication or convert people out of it
because that's crazy and and so that was
revised and so now she's just going well
this is clearly just a mental illness
vice versa and then doctors committing
in the case of children especially this
medical malpractice trying to turn this
fantasy into reality and creating
incredibly negative short and long-term
consequences both this is nuts okay tool
C is nuts physically and psychologically
and so that's really the question that
we the American people have to to ask
ourselves and to answer is are we going
to live in a society of Common Sense and
reality or are we going to buy into this
Insanity uh and this fantasy are we
going to allow and this is one of the
reasons I left the Democratic party
right now we know why she left we have
the Democratic party of today uh selling
this fantasy and and Catering to it and
giving credibility to this fantasy these
mental delusions all because they think
it'll give them more political power a
party that is willing to do anything
especially things that are damaging to
Children right this is so crazy the idea
that you're going to get so this so I
don't even know where so as far as the
Kaylee filling in for Tucker it's a joke
it's just terrible but she was better
than some of the people who have tried
so far but the the content was just
absolutely disgusting the idea that it I
don't know at this point what the
prevalence of
um of trans is in the general population
and part of it is are are we actually
correctly assessing that number is
everybody even kind of willing to say it
or but it it seems like it's
extraordinarily small it's under well
under one percent
the idea that the Democratic party has
this Brave and Bold exciting strategy to
gain political power
by catering to the I'm using their
terminology by quote catering to the
quote delusions
of a tiny tiny tiny tiny sliver of the
population
it's just a very stupid strategy and
obviously that's not what it is it's
about a reaction to the rights attack on
this marginalized group of people that's
what we're dealing with here so tulsey's
lost her mind
um the Tucker replacement Fiasco is not
going well and we'll continue following
it to see what happens with Fox news
they've got another at least one more
lawsuit at least two more lawsuits
they're dealing with maybe three we will
follow it all of the clips I played here
for you
can find them on our YouTube channel you
can find them on our Instagram on our
Tick Tock they're really almost too
available to be perfectly honest
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today we
welcome to the program democratic
congresswoman Barbara Lee representing
California's 12th congressional district
also a candidate for the senate seat
currently held by Senator Dianne
Feinstein congresswoman really a
pleasure having you on I appreciate your
time nice being with you Dave so I mean
just to start with some of the things
that are that are going on right now yet
again we find ourselves in this position
of talking about the debt ceiling and
are we going to default and who's
posturing politically and for what
different reasons just as someone who's
been through a number of cycles of this
is this even remotely interesting at
this point or is it just a feeling of
exhaustion that this has to happen time
and time again
no it's not a feeling of exhaustion I
feel like uh that the Republicans
especially the mega Republicans have
politicized this to the point where it's
it's confusing oftentimes to the public
when you incurred debts and remember a
large portion of these debts were
incurred under Donald Trump uh with his
tax giveaways to corporations in the
mega Rich when you incur your debt uh
you're obligated to pay it and when you
buy a car you pay your car note if you
default on your car note they
repossessed the car and then if you go
to get another car the interest rates
will go up if in fact you can purchase
another car and and so why they're
politicizing this uh is primarily to
speak to their base and to the mega
Republicans who want to basically uh
take away uh and cut Social Security cut
veterans Health cut Medicare and all of
the cuts that they want to take place
around using people's lives really as
Hospital it for the debt ceiling and
that's unacceptable we must pay our
bills then we talk about how we
negotiate around the budget I'm a member
of the budget committee and the
Appropriations Committee and that's the
process that should be used at this
point do you operate in congress with
the belief that something like the debt
ceiling debate which feels so distant to
the lives of so many Americans who just
they go to work they might bring kids to
school they're living their lives do you
operate with the belief or assumption
that something like the debt ceiling
debate can be used both positively and
negatively electorally or that it's the
type of thing that just turns people off
well I think people need to uh
understand the Dynamics when you talk
about debt ceiling uh we have to break
it down and I looked at uh Kevin
McCarthy the speaker the speaker's
District I mean thousands of people will
lose jobs thousands of people in his
district will lose their veterans
benefit thousands of people uh their
retirement savings will be uh cut by at
least uh twenty thousand dollars so
thousands of people in his district
alone are going to be impacted uh when
you look at child care when you look at
uh early childhood education when you
look at uh college education young
people need to have college this is debt
free it's going to cost a heck of a lot
more for young people to go to college
if we defaulted on the debt so this has
real impact on people's lives and that's
why we're fighting so hard as Democrats
to get these Republicans to understand
we must pay our debts we didn't have
this issue under Donald Trump I mean I
think we raised the debt ceiling what
three times uh and that you know the
Republicans were fighting and so this is
a political issue they're trying to
cater to the base to Marjorie Taylor
green and they really don't care about
whose lives that they're hurting but
believe you me Republican lives in
Republican districts and red States and
blue States people are going to be hurt
in a big way if in fact we don't do this
congresswoman with the benefit of
hindsight we're now able to have quite
quite a precise conversation about
something like Afghanistan if we go back
to the moment decades ago when you were
the only member of Congress to vote
against the authorization of military
force in Afghanistan after 9 11 and we
now go to Joe Biden carrying out some
version of the plan Donald Trump wanted
to carry out to get us out of
Afghanistan which while not perfect I
believe was absolutely the right
decision what can we now say in some
total about that now that we have this
these two decades AIDS going back to
your vote against that authorization all
the way through to the exit although
some contractors remain what what's the
what's the retrospective on Afghanistan
well first of all yes I voted against
the authorization because it came three
days after the horrific attack on our
country first of all thousands of people
were died still thousands of people are
are dealing with the health impacts of
what took place uh and it was a 60 word
authorization three days after this
horrific attack that authorized not only
President Bush but any subsequent
president to go to war without coming
back to Congress that's unconstitutional
I mean we debate and authorize or not
the use of force for specific actions
not giving the executive branch
congresses which is the people's voice
authority and there's no way I could
vote for that that was overly Broad and
it was it set the stage for Perpetual
Awards fast forward to today we uh have
used this the administration all
Administration since the Bush
Administration has used this in I think
19 or 20 countries non-related to 911 41
times even uh and the Congressional
research study provided a Declassified
report it's been used for domestic
surveillance in our own country and so
this is was overly broad as I said it
was uh we needed to debate and come up
with an appropriate response I'm not
looking at the world through
rose-colored glasses I mean I know we
have to have some form of a response but
you have to have a rational response
that's appropriate not three days after
while people are mourning grieving and
angry and so now I'm trying to repeal
this authorization and I've got
bipartisan support to do that but the
problem and the sticking point is
there's some who want to repeal and
replace well what do you replace it with
the president has to come to Congress to
have an authorization to replace
whatever he needs the authorization to
use for as far so my repeal
authorization stays in place for eight
months if president determines he or she
needs an authorization to go to war come
back to Congress will debate it and
provide it or not
what's your view on the withdrawal from
Afghanistan which you know it it wasn't
perfect but I believe it was the right
decision uh there was there were a
number of criticisms made of Joe Biden's
withdrawal but when the former president
Donald Trump was initially asked what he
would have done differently he wasn't
really able to articulate anything that
he would have done differently so it
seems that maybe there would have been
some chaos no matter when it happened
what's your sense of it well my sense of
it is that it had to be done and yes it
was chaotic it wasn't planned but
remember this was set up by Donald Trump
yes and he made and so uh President
Biden did the right thing it could have
been done uh in a more organized fashion
where uh we could have uh I think uh
done the it could have really provided a
better uh safe passage for those
especially who protected U.S troops and
who supported the U.S in uh in
Afghanistan uh the population uh but he
had to do this because in most military
officials will tell you uh we'd be there
20 more years and then 20 more years
there was no military solution in
Afghanistan and so why would we stay
there another 20 years uh our young men
and women serve bravely we lost a lot of
troops a lot of our young men and women
have health impacts that will be with
them for the rest of their life types we
have to make sure that they have the
type of Medical Care the employment and
support that they need which of course
the Republicans are reticent to give and
and to support so yes President Biden
did the right thing no it was done uh
well no it was not done in an orderly
way but the historical context has to be
looked at in what Donald Trump promised
and how uh President Biden had to
execute right away and that was what
took place
congresswoman I want to talk a little
bit about the senate race that you're
involved in right now this is a very
interesting race we we've interviewed
Adam Schiff your colleague and opponent
in that race we hope to speak to Katie
Porter also your colleague and opponent
in that race you know I get so many
emails about that race and one of the
big concerns that people have is that
there are three congressional seats here
that are going to be vacated which
hopefully would be filled by democrats
all for one senate seat which also if
Dianne Feinstein were to resign at least
in the short term Gavin Newsom would get
to appoint someone Gavin Newsom has said
if he had that opportunity he would
appoint a black woman Adam Schiff very
nice guy not a black woman Katie Porter
same thing so talk to me about the
Dynamics of this race are there
discussions within the halls of Congress
about the fact that these three
California House Seats will be up for
grab talk us through it a little bit
well I'm very focused on my race first
of all I have a very strong Democratic
District so I'm confident that we will
elect a Democrat uh in the 12th
congressional district and yes I'm
running I was one of those that the
governor had considered once once uh
vice president Kamala Harris resigned
and of course the governor appointed who
was a good friend and doing a great job
Senator Alex Padilla but the governor
did say if he had an appointing
authority that he would appoint an
African-American woman but let me tell
you I am running and going back to when
he said that there were two
African-American women at the top of his
list one was at least we heard that was
mayor Karen bass and myself but I
decided uh when I after I talked to
Senator Feinstein in December that she
was going to make her announcement very
soon whether she was going to run or not
run and I waited until she made her
announcement that she was not going to
run that was in February of course my
opponents were running already yes but I
waited I filed the next day after she
announced she was not running and I'm
running and I think that my experience
my background my lived experiences as
well as my experiences as a negotiator
and as a progressive black woman and as
someone who fights not only for
marginalized communities but for
everyone for the middle class for
Working Families for people to have uh
the quality of life that they deserve an
economy that works for all people who
have are not been seen you know here in
California we have 20 20 of our
populations one paycheck away from
poverty no one in the Senate is fighting
for the poor and low-income people and
Working Families you don't hear that
debate you don't hear the debate around
climate change that uh and and
addressing climate the climate crisis
with uh environmental justice as part of
that in terms of what we do to mitigate
the harm of low-income communities I I
am running in this race on a platform to
talk about inequality and housing and
and my shared experiences I had an
abortion when I was 15 and a half years
old I co-chaired the pro-choice caucus I
fought to end the height Amendment uh I
had I talked about what happened during
my abortion not only uh did I do that
well I did that because finally with the
Texas decision I felt like the public
should know that they're members of
Congress who have these shared
experiences and I'm inviting them to
make sure that we codify abortion care
into our law and so I have many many
experiences as a small business owner
former small business owner as a person
who started Community Mental Health
Center my background is mental health
I'm at my MSW psychiatric social work at
mental health so big issue here in
California and throughout the country
and so I think my experiences my ability
to negotiate my standing strong
sometimes having to take on my party
when I think they're wrong and and I
have courage enough to do that because
this is who I am and of course there are
gaps in the Senate there are no black
women in the Senate of that perspective
The Experience uh representation matters
David representation matters it seems
there are basically three story lines
that are playing the largest role in
what are still the relatively early days
of this campaign one storyline is
identity as you talk about a third story
line is who is the true or most
Progressive and the third story line is
experience versus age and sort of like
what the voters are are looking for it
seems as though this could get a little
bit awkward in the sense that I know you
get along well with your colleagues from
from California it do you have some
conversation where everybody says hey
let's keep this clean or or it strikes
me as the type of thing that could
become awkward well I don't think it's
going to be okay I mean it's a campaign
right
but uh believe you me I know for a fact
myself people don't like uh campaigns
where uh you're hidden below the belt
and I was always and I was mentored by
congresswoman uh rondells uh I worked
for Ron for 11 years he was first black
chair of the armed services committee
and Ron always told me and and everyone
on his staff you debate the policy you
think made experiences you debate what
your your historical context and how
you're going to use that for the future
to make lives better you don't hit below
the belt you don't go personal you don't
so uh no I I don't do that I mean I'm
going to defend myself yes if their lies
told about me I mean come on but uh I
don't think it's an awkward campaign
it's a this is a democracy people put
out their record who they are what they
stand for what they've done and what
they're going to do in the future and
then people vote based on who they think
will best represent them well I'll tell
you a campaign based on policy sounds so
refreshing given the context in which
the Republican party has abandoned even
pretending to talk about policy so that
I think would be welcomed by by many
many voters we wish you the best in the
campaign we've been speaking with
congresswoman Barbara Lee representing
California's 12th congressional district
I really appreciate your time and
insights today thank you David nice
being with you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's continue with a couple
of other stories that I want to mention
to you the George Soros anti-semitic
media control conspiracy theory is now
coming out
forcefully from the mouth of the failed
former president Donald Trump Trump's
campaign in an email fundraising email
now suggests that George Soros controls
the media this is an email that went out
I believe it's yesterday this is from
Trump asking for money and there's not
even the pretense anymore that they are
doing anything short of just completely
adopting the standard hardcore
right-wing conspiracy theories Trump's
fundraising email rights friend of all
the vile witch hunts and schemes the
radical left Democrats have concocted
since I first came down the golden
escalator this one may truly be the most
despicable because they're not just
trying to silence me
they're trying to cancel out your vote
Soros and his globalist cabal remember
that globalist is often used as a
catch-all for Jews when you can't when
you can't say Jews Soros and his
globalist cabal are attempting to buy
out the media control the airwaves and
guarantee crooked Joe Biden whatever
coverage he desires then they Source a
headline from the Western Journal not
exactly uh the Associated Press which
says Soros group preparing to swoop in
and buy major media company out of
bankruptcy report which
um is a completely different thing from
we're trying to control the media and
give Joe Biden the coverage he wants
this is your standard
generic
anti-semitic conspiracy theory and what
you know people who look at this stuff
closely and have been following it for a
long time as we have you understand that
this is all about
some people just
work in Media
but the Jews
conspire to control the media and that's
the kind of Kernel that's at the heart
of many of these anti-semitic media
control or control banking that's
another one Soros and uh whoever else
they're controlling banking it's not
just oh there are groups that are
different differently represented in
different Industries oh okay well we
could talk about historical reasons why
that is no big deal great conversation
we've had it many times no it's about
the cabal the globalist cabal Soros and
other Jews you have to understand that
that's what's what's under the surface
here
working together
to their benefit and to the detriment of
everybody else to control the media Etc
so we don't have to spend a lot of time
on this in the sense that I know many of
you already know and understand this
conspiracy theory it doesn't need to be
explained to you and those of you who at
this point insist on denying that that's
what this conspiracy theory is I'm
certainly not going to be able to
convince you but the news is for lack of
a better term Trump now overtly doing
this in fundraising emails new possible
issue along the lines of it's not the
crime it's the cover-up
potentially afflicting Donald Trump it
is now being explored whether Trump
provided doctored Mar-A-Lago security
footage now let me back up and remind
you what this is about
we saw Trump's Mar-A-Lago home
um some call it raided a search warrant
was served people often get very upset
if you use one term or the other they
are often used interchangeably a search
warrant was indeed served at Mar-A-Lago
related to classified documents that
Donald Trump was asked to return and he
didn't and it's a major major
investigation that we've talked about
before one aspect of this is security
footage and there are now questions as
to whether
parts of the security footage were
removed or doctored by people working
for Donald Trump a couple articles about
this Esquire reports special counsel
Jack Smith has a few questions from
Mar-A-Lago security for example what
happened with the handling of
surveillance footage they subpoenaed a
Charlie Pierce
wrote this article and says lordy there
may be doctored tapes at least according
to CNL CNN Special counsel Jack Smith
has his special suspicions quoting the
handling of the footage and how
employees within the Trump organization
responded to the Justice Department's
demand for it have prompted a new round
of grand jury subpoenas to top Trump
employees in the last few weeks sources
told CNN longtime Trump organization
executive Matthew calamari and his son
Matthew calamari Jr are expected to
appear before the grand jury
investigating possible mishandling
prosecutors are expected to ask them
about the handling of the surveillance
footage and Trump employees
conversations following the subpoena
possible mishandling is prosecutor ease
for we've got these techies you see and
they're very good and they have some
questions the question here is about
whether the video surveillance footage
was indeed doctored Yahoo news sorry CBS
News via Yahoo life also writes about
this security camera video from Trump's
Mar-A-Lago Resort under scrutiny so
we've heard this term before this this
term it's not the crime it's the
cover-up
that really could play a major role here
and in fact as as we've talked about
before this has really been a theme of
much of the uh many of the troubles that
Donald Trump has had since he became
president
um even if we go back to the Mueller
probe the Russia probe As Trump calls it
Russia Russia Russia uh if from day one
trumpet merely said
uh I will cooperate with your
investigation we did nothing wrong I am
now president I'm focusing on running
the in uh the country and I will not be
making any public statements in order to
not Prejudice or influence or meddle
with this investigation ninety percent
of the Mueller probe would not have
taken place a lot of what ended up
happening was self-inflicted because
Donald Trump couldn't keep his mouth
shut and similarly
um you know you you've got the handling
of the documents themselves and that
would be adjudicated investigated
potentially adjudicated in the future
but if indeed the security footage
showing documents being moved around
shows uh that the documents were
deliberately hidden then you've got
layer one of the cover-up and then if
you've doctored the security footage of
you trying to hide the documents related
to the original inquiry we've now have
we have a second layer of cover-up which
could play a major role so we will watch
it that's the latest suspicion from the
special counsel and we will see what
comes of that
Steve Bannon is now going after me on
his program let me give you the back
story about this we did a segment
um a couple of weeks ago I guess it was
about an actual crazy person as I
described her going on Steve bannon's
program
and talking about all of the horrible
things that the satanic temple is doing
now as I've talked to you before the
satanic temple is not a scary
organization the satanic temple is no
less valid than any other religion first
and foremost and it turns out that the
person uh fear-mongering about the
satanic temple on Steve bannon's show
was actually his sister Mary Beth Bannon
and uh Steve Bannon seems to be
increasingly obsessed with the satanic
temple stuff but he now has gone after
me so here's the start of a clip from I
guess this was uh three days ago on his
show he interviews some guy about the
satanic temple stuff and then you'll see
that they cut to my segment about this
okay here's just a few seconds isn't the
issue you got these parents and it just
takes a couple kiss because the way
they're selling it we played the jingles
on uh and showed the videos on Saturday
I think my sister was here she she
brought up because a lot of people she
knows word about this right they make it
into self-empowerment okay so that
segment in which he brought his sister
on is the segment that we critiqued so
then as you can see he actually plays my
segment and we're going to go to the end
of it you've already seen my segment and
it's available I don't think we actually
need to play the whole thing but here's
the end of it and then it goes into
Bannon attacking me take a look clear
that there are certain things that it's
not just a difference of opinion it's
not it's it's something much more
pernicious and more than that okay we're
gonna that's that's brother that's
brother Dave Pacman uh he's got a a show
true that's his analysis and we're doing
this as a teaching exercise many of you
remember that interview
from a couple of weeks ago but we also
played the Liberty Council who came on
afterwards and and talked about
everybody's very worried about the
satanic temple this is a real thing it's
not mental but you see how the left
what they want to do immediately
they don't want to dress they never want
to talk about what the thing is now
unfortunately for Steve we've talked
about what the thing is many times we've
interviewed Lucian Graves from the
Satanic Temple at least once now I don't
know if it's once or twice it's been a
while that we've been doing interviews
we have gone into detail about the ways
in which the satanic temple Compares and
contrasts to other religions we've
talked about the principles of the
satanic temple we have talked about the
thing
Steve Bannon doesn't want you to know
that or doesn't know that himself I want
to talk about what the issue is they all
they always want to um uh do an end
around or do a a uh a uh something to
Take Your Eye Off the Ball oh right
we're not going to fall for that oh
we know that these satanic clubs and the
Liberty Council has a different
Viewpoint that made the parents that are
in these school systems have okay all
right so anyway listen uh Steve Bannon
is welcome on this program quite
literally anytime I'm not super
interested in talking with him about the
satanic temple but I guess if that's
what it takes to get him on I'm willing
to willing to do it there are many other
things I would like to talk to Steve
Bannon about including his role in
bringing forward one of the most
disastrous presidencies in the history
of the United States certainly in the
last 50 years he's welcome on the
program quite literally anytime we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's the caller asking why
didn't I do heavy promotion of the Lex
Freedman interview that I did take a
listen David it's Alan from Jersey I'm
online and I see you did an interview
with Lex Friedman the world famous Lex
Friedman of the Lex Friedman podcast I
can't believe when did this happen how
did this happen where did this come from
David such a big you know
earth-shattering event of this you
should have been promoting is David you
should have told us you're scheduling it
and then after it was scheduled you
should have said this is when it's going
to happen and then say this and then say
it just happened and then say it just
happened yesterday and then say it
happened two days ago then say Lex told
me it's going to take three or four more
days before it's posted David why didn't
you give us every single update of every
single step in the process of you doing
Lex freedom and people would want to
know that type of information but
instead you gave us no warning okay so
here's the deal
many of you know that I hesitate to
pre-promote things especially things
Beyond My Control
because sadly they often get canceled or
postponed they never happen and then
people end up asking what happened and
in fact The Lex Friedman interview was
originally scheduled for a couple months
ago and I did pre-promote it on a couple
of live streams and then it did get
canceled at the very last minute and
then I had nothing I was there I was
sitting there holding my hat as people
say
um so this time around when it got
rescheduled I just didn't say a word
about it in case it got canceled again
and unfortunately this happens with
interviews we do on our show then they
get canceled perfect example is today's
Barbara Lee interview that we finally
did in aired today with you
it was postponed five times
and so imagine if I had promoted right
after the Adam Schiff interview hey and
tomorrow we've got barbarelli coming up
who's also running for that same Dianne
Feinstein senate seat and then I'm left
holding my hat and we have no interview
and then it's not clear what happened so
that's why I am now kind of cautious
about pre-promoting things that I don't
totally control
because they so often end up postponed
all right that's why but now the Lex
Friedman interview is out check it out I
posted it to my Twitter I posted it to
my blue Ski Blue Sky by the way are you
on Blue Sky please follow me on Blue Sky
I think it's actually a fantastic
platform it is invite only right now but
the invites are going out very strongly
follow me on Blue Sky
um it's on Lex's YouTube channel it's
everywhere we've got a great bonus show
for you today should the US get rid of
the debt ceiling is that a possible way
to get Beyond this periodic predictable
debt ceiling uh situation we can discuss
that on the bonus show what did the
California panel on reparations say
about what should be done with regard to
reparations we will discuss and lastly
the Biden Administration has some
interesting new plans for requiring
Airlines to pay stranded passengers
cover meals cover hotels in a much more
powerful way than is required right now
does this make sense is it over
regulation is it a nanny state or is it
just consumer protection all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com
if you don't have the pleasure of the
bonus show then we'll see you back here
tomorrow